please take a look at dc's teacher of
the year
eton elementary is a school in
washington d.c
it is in ward 7 northeast d.c
this community has been underserved for
several years however
this community is filled with such
cultural wealth
my personal mission always has been to
give my students access to a variety of
people
programs resources and connections to
and really enhance their learning
experience
we actually reached out to asus
and they are giving us enough asus
chromebooks
for every single student and teacher at
ayton elementary
i like can't even fathom this this is
crazy
that was alejandro diaz granados a
teacher at aton elementary
and today we've sent abc 7 reporter kid
o'shea to his house for what alejandro
thinks is just a quick follow-up but
we actually have a very special surprise
are you guys ready
[Applause]
all right let's do this hi guys
hi hi drew we are here with alejandro or
as his students at a town elementary
nomads
mr diaz yes it's good to see you drew hi
alejandro
i'm so happy to see you what an
incredible
year you're having after we did
our show together uh you won a very
important award
i did i did so uh after our show i was
nominated and chosen for the dc teacher
of the year and
i just recently found out that i was
also selected
as a finalist for the national teacher
of the year award and as well as the
national university
award um you know so it's been
incredible you know for
teachers to be recognized during a time
when
you know teachers are working so hard so
i'm just grateful and happy to even be
able to receive that
and you've done so much to work with
your kids in the classroom and keep them
engaged during these times
tell us about some of the stuff that
you've been doing with them at school
yeah i mean so
uh we've been virtual and some of the
things that we do i mean we have so much
fun we
uh the students do yoga they bring their
pets on screen so they got to meet my
dog margot and i get to meet like their
pet snake
gizmo and we just do all types of
incredible things you know today we met
with
the embassy of uganda as well so you
know they are
just uh just great to have in the
classroom that's
awesome and alejandro like what does the
national
university teacher award nomination
mean to you yeah so the national
university teacher award
is incredible that was uh the first time
i was even recognized for any sort of
award
and you know it's so huge because you
know teachers are working so hard during
this pandemic and
to even be recognized is something i'm
just extremely grateful for and
you know teachers work so hard and i
wasn't even inspired to become a teacher
if it wasn't for one of my former
teachers mr harris from my middle school
you know he would come in every single
day with a shirt and tie and
uh you know had a fresh haircut and this
is my first teacher who resembled my
background
so that it really inspired me to become
a teacher and you know national
university
focuses and highlights inspiring
teachers so you know it's just
incredible
and i'm being told actually right now
that we
actually have an update from
that about the award and i think we can
bring in dr
michael cunningham from national
university are you there
i'm here hello everyone hi drew hi
hi everybody hello
so alejandro it is indeed my pleasure to
announce
that you have been selected as the grand
winner
of the national university teacher of
the year award
[Applause]
we chose you because you believe and
inspire your students each and every day
now i have some more good news as the
winner you just received this fifty
thousand dollar check
which you can spend any way you want and
you also will receive
a full ride scholarship to the social
emotional
masters program at nash university
so congratulations stay safe
[Applause]
i'm at a loss for words thank you thank
you so much
wow i can't i'm i just don't know what
to say i mean
you know i've had inspirational teachers
in my life who have you know
uh really have worked hard to make sure
that i'm in the place where i am now
so i'm just extremely grateful drew you
know national university i really really
appreciate this this is really
incredible
thank you dr cunningham so
much for doing this with us on this show
so thank you for letting our show be a
part of your prestigious
recognition of alejandro thank you dr
cunningham
so much pleasure keep up the great work
alejandro thank you
so so much and i gotta give it up to my
dear friend kid o'shea who's like
literally the one who helped us pull
this off and it is so nice
to be working with you and let this
please be the beginning of
many elaborate cool schemes we do
together
i love it how does it feel i'm in shock
drew how did you
keep this a secret i just had no idea
i mean oh i'm just so appreciative drew
i mean we're like best friends now tell
douglas i said hello
it's true let's keep the good times
rolling
please and kid yes thank you so much
and my deepest appreciation to dr
cunningham go to our website to find out
more about the national university and
how to nominate
a teacher in your community you guys
you're the best congratulations i'll see
you soon